he was definitely a man for all people
but he was he was a very personal person
i don't think many really knew
who the inner soul of tony shea was
and he was he was peter pan he really
was a peter pan
and it's just a tragic loss
he is responsible for helping downtown
las vegas find its feet again
former zappos ceo tony shea poured
millions of dollars into the city
while his company helped change online
shopping friday night
shea died after a house fire in
connecticut shea was really a local
legend and his
unexpected passing at just 46 years old
was a shock to those
he most inspired the investigation into
how that fire killed shea is ongoing a
lot of questions
not a lot of answers thank you for
joining us at six o'clock i'm brian
loftis
and i'm denise valdez the i-team's david
charns has been digging into
just exactly what happened he's live in
downtown las vegas tonight outside of
zappos headquarters
with more information and of course
that's the company that tony shea used
to run
david
and denise tony shea just meant so much
to downtown las vegas and his former
employees here at zappos i want to show
you the memorial that's been set up here
some candles balloons and cards tonight
we're learning his official cause of
death
is smoke inhalation and radio calls
between firefighters
are helping piece some of this puzzle
together five hundred peak
for a fire inside of a house one person
barricaded inside of a room
the first sign of trouble came at 3 30
in the morning
firefighters called to this waterfront
connecticut home for a man stuck
inside a burning shed it's going to be
an actual shed
that's attached to the exterior of the
house and the
male is there inside according to real
estate records the home has guest
quarters in the basement with a
fireplace
kitchen and attached shed which exits to
a pool area
it's not clear if shea was barricaded in
the shed as
radio transmissions indicate or if he
was somehow stuck inside
fire officials tell the i-team they had
to force their way in
to pull shea out and they say others in
the house
were able to escape we have one victim
being pulled from the fire now
unresponsive shea was later transferred
to a burn center in another part of the
state
the i-team has confirmed the home is
owned by rachel brown
a long-time zappos employee records show
brown bought the house this past
august and according to those radio
calls it does appear the fire began
in the basement where according to
records there's a fireplace
but right now it's unclear how that fire
started or how shea became trapped
inside that storage area video from in
front of the house monday shows no
visible damage
in a car parked in the driveway
now we did reach out to brown and we
have not heard back the medical examiner
in connecticut tells me that
shea's death has been ruled accidental
but they are waiting for some tests to
come back
and that is standard procedure live in
downtown las vegas tonight i'm david
shawn day news now
and david are those tests standard
procedure
yeah they are so in any sort of
accidental death or
death where there needs to be some more
investigation
they'll send out those blood tests to an
outside company
technically takes just a couple more
days to get that information but
any medical examiner is going to want
that information as part of their
investigation and also
to have on a person's death certificate
so it could be a couple more weeks
before we have that information